In Android 4.4 KitKat or API level 19,
Android started getting really
serious about coordinated motion.
The new scenes and
transitions API made it much
easier to define how UI
elements should move together.
Let's take a look.
The scenes and transitions API
introduced a new paradigm for
animating objects in your UI.
James gave you a glimpse into this API,
but
it actually let's you
do a whole lot more.
The API allows you to define different
states for your UI, called scenes.
There's actually two scenes
in this example here.
And also, let you define ways to
transition between those scenes,
coordinating several
UI elements at once.
So, when UI elements appear,
disappear, move,
or otherwise change, you could
easily define the animations to use.
In this example, you can see
some of those elements moving,
some elements appearing,
and some disappearing.
Pressing the info or close button,
switches between those two scenes.
The way this works, is you have two
layouts which describe the two scenes.
Here's what they look like.
They're pretty simple,
just some linear layouts,
some relative layouts, image views,
text views, and buttons.
Now the magic happens here
in the onClick handlers.
When you press the info button,
we use this new TransitionManager class,
to change from the current
scene to the other one,
as defined by the second layout file.
If we don't specify anything else,
Android will automatically figure
out some nice transitions for you.
Moving elements shared
between the scenes.
Fading new elements in, and
fading old elements out.
But let's say we wanted to
customize the transition.
We could do things like
stagger the transition so
that not everything happens all at once.
For that, you could your describe
custom transitions in XML, and
pass them into the TransitionManager,
like so.
And here's an example of
the custom transition XML.
There's some similarities with the
animation XML we talked about before.
But the primitives you're working with,
like changeBounds and
fade, are a bit different.
As you can see, the animation
capabilities in Android have been
evolving, from basic
animations in early Android
to much richer capabilities in Ice
Cream Sandwich, Jelly Bean and KitKat.
Let's go to Nick,
who will tell us about the new animation
capabilities in Android 5.0, Lollipop.